well Las Vegas mom is pleading with the
community be on the lookout for her teen
son she says no one has seen or heard
from the 15 year old since early
Thursday afternoon he was last seen near
Palo Verde High School on the far west
side of the valley Victoria Saha joins
us live with more on his last
whereabouts Victoria
Metro Police say they are considering
this as a runaway case but are still
putting together all their resources to
help bring Donovan home now it's been
four days since Donovan was last seen
here right by Palo Verde and his mom is
fearing the worst
Flyers with pictures of Donovan jamai
are surrounding Palo Verde High School
Monday morning several alumni from the
school gathered to personally hand up
fires and brainstorm where could Donovan
be there was a house that has like a
camera a ring camera pointing right
towards the street his mom goddess
Johnson says as she knew something was
wrong when Donovan didn't come home
after school he just wouldn't just pop
up and leaves Johnson says it's been
four days of Agony not knowing where her
son is no sleep no eating she says
Donovan didn't return to school after
they had a fire drill Thursday Metro
Police telling us that they have
considered Donovan to be a runaway but
his mom says it's still a worry any
child can be in danger when they're not
home retired captain of Nevada State
Police and now private investigator
Scott Martin Echoes that we have the
strip there's all sorts of dangers there
too and for parents of teens there could
be hidden signs you could look out for
sharing where they're going what they're
doing if they're holding their phone
close and they don't want to share in
info Johnson says her son was last seen
wearing a blue sweatshirt khaki pants
and a checkered backpack that looks like
this if anybody out there has seen my
son Donovan if you're listening please
just call me please let me know you're
okay
here is another look at Donovan's
picture if you have any information you
are asked to call police reporting near
Pavilion Center and Alta Victoria Saha
ain't news now
well Metro Police tells Victoria a case
like this where a juvenile is missing
they are considered endangered only if
they have made comments of self-harm or
are without the medication that they
need as for Donovan as Victoria
mentioned he is considered a runaway but
this is still an open and active case
with the missing person's unit